make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we are picking back up with the
juggernaut right the juggernaut series
over here at marvel comics and i know
this is something that we don't we kind
of cover
not really inconsistently but marvel
does it once a month right so we kind of
have to just wait it out a little bit
and at the moment right now i believe
we're at issue number four and i think
we have another week or two
before issue number five comes out maybe
a little bit longer than that what this
does
is this kind of picks up off the heels
of the last story that we did right in
the sense that uh we ended up learning
that arnhem zola the one time
member of hydra uh who's long since been
defected from the group and kind of
doing his own thing
had basically been kidnapping people who
were mutants and then
more or less experimenting on them right
so in a lot of ways kind of taking over
the role that was previously assigned to
mr sinister in the x-men comics uh now
the funny thing about this this was kind
of interesting here is that arnhem zola
at least as we're told is operating out
of an old factor three base now factor
three this was kind of quite
kind of wild here factor three this is
an old school organization right so
factor three was created in
uncanny x-men number 28 i want to say i
think it was just x-men number 28 back
in the day by roy thomas um
they're an old-school enemy of the x-men
they weren't really like a big deal
right i mean they were kind of a group
that was introduced before the era of
claremont when like groups were a lot
more nuanced a lot more
uh subversive and and really a lot more
dangerous you know in the the
claremont era of uncanny x-men but it is
kind of cool to see an old throwback
but the idea is that as soon as
juggernaut gets in here he's immediately
attacked by primus now primus goes all
the way back to the old captain america
and falcon comics back in 1977 right so
this is not
a new concept but primus as it existed
was really just kind of a wholesale
creation by arnhem zola not really a
modification of an existing person
but really just a complete and total
creation but the idea behind
primus and really what made privacy so
dangerous in the old school marvel
comics and even now to a degree
is the fact that he's really just a
malleable plastic character right he's
just kind of this android that can
essentially do whatever it is that he
needs to do in order to overcome an
enemy in terms of adjusting himself
right so think of it as something very
similar to mr fantastic
of the fantastic four now for the most
part with jeffy not facing off against
this guy it's like being tied up in
string
and in fact when he's basically captured
by primus it's because primus kind of
turns itself into a sort of gelatinous
state and then bonds itself to
to juggernaut which basically sort of
solidifies him right it just kind of
keeps him in case
but following him being knocked out we
kind of get this little bit of a
throwback
about about a few months ago we're not
given an actual definitive date but at
some point a few months ago that with
kane marco showing back
up and then trying to you know having
the crimson bands and then from there
trying to re-access his uh his power as
the juggernaut he ends up breaking into
a storage facility that belongs to one
now the one stands for office of
national emergency and this was an
organization that largely rose to
prominence in the aftermath of
decimation or really during the events
of decimation
the aftermath of house of amp right when
the mutant population lost its powers or
at least 98 of the mutant population
lost his powers the office of national
emergency basically reactivated the
sentinel program but they were manned
sentinels the other thing they did too
is they kind of made the x-men prisoners
not directly but in so far as
as what was left of the mutant
population resigned itself to the
grounds of the xavier institute and then
under cyclops
basically nobody was allowed to leave
right and the sentinels basically
existed there under the auspices
of hey we're going to protect you guys
from various threats out there all the
while the x-men were basically prisoners
they just weren't really allowed to go
anywhere right so it was
kind of the x-men turning to an
authority thing you were to keep them
safe all the while making themselves
prisoners of that authority figure
and just not realizing it and so
following that with kane marco
basically re-accessing the the the kind
of shards of the
the crimson gem of sidorak and then kind
of reactivating his juggernaut powers
through the crimson bands that he
currently possesses he's met by the
disembodied voice of
sidorak himself and so we're going to
kind of jump forward here for a second
technically in the story but what it
does is it yanks him directly to the
crimson dimension right now
one of the things to understand when it
comes to sidorak and we really haven't
covered his character all too much but
one of the important things to
understand when it comes to sidorak is
in his own dimension
he's wildly powerful and in fact there's
been multiple instances in the case of
marvel comics where it's been stated
that if sidorak were to leave his
dimension
and show up in the main marvel universe
with all his powers intact basically
operating at 100 of his powers nobody
could stop him right not dormammu not
doctor strange
nobody right this guy is just a whole
nother level of power
it's really insane but such as it is
he's confined really to his own crimson
dimension
and can't really leave and that's where
juggernaut comes into play right
juggernaut's kind of the extension of
sidorak on earth and allowing him to
kind of do his own thing but the crazy
thing about this
is that what we're told here is
traditionally the armor given to
juggernaut and the empowerment of the
the crimson gem basically anchors him to
sidorak right it's how cetera was able
to act through him
over the years uh during the eighth day
event for example when sidorak basically
took total control or at least gave
juggernaut almost 100 of his power and
the juggernaut went forward just on a
whole new level of strength that we'd
never really seen before uh that was all
sidorak acting through him the
difference is that these
bands that he has largely seem to be
bands that are tied to the bands that
doctor strange uses right the crimson
bands of sidorak
you guys have heard doctor strange using
that spell before they're essentially
seeming to be tied to doctor strange's
power in some way we're not given a
definitive explanation here the
important thing about
this though is that the the gems itself
because they were kind of destroyed but
now reconstituted
what it does is it allows juggernaut to
go forward as a person who acts
autonomously of sidorak
basically meaning he's not anchored to
them or anchored to him so when sidorak
says like you have now returned to me as
my
my earthly avatar go forward and do my
bidding the response to juggernaut is
you know that's not going to happen i've
not been whisked here to your realm i'm
here in a mind state but physically i'm
still back on earth i'll no longer
do your bidding i'll do whatever i want
to do right now it really kind of begs
the question this is what we do not get
an answer to
it really kind of begs the question if
juggernaut's powered by the crimson gym
with sidorak
uh and he goes forward wearing the
crimson bands and the crimson bands are
basically a source of power
linked to doctor strange by sidorak then
effectively he's still anchored to him
no he doesn't necessarily have to do his
bidding but by all standards of
measurement his power can be taken away
and so the question becomes if that's
the case
why is it not happen right why didn't
sidorak just strip him of his power and
all we're given is this kind of loose
explanation i'm not directly anchored to
you anymore so what it seems like is for
whatever reason the power of sidorak is
still confined to the crimson gym but
the crimson gem
cannot be accessed by sidorak right so
he basically cannot cut the juggernaut
off from a source of power
so to give this a more tangible
perspective it's like cutting off a
person's hand right it doesn't belong to
them anymore it's just
in the possession of whoever it is that
has that hand they can't do anything
with it they can't move their fingers or
anything like that that's basically what
it looks like which is kind of
interesting because it seems to defy
this
you know omnipotent power of cenorak but
it's also cool because it moves
juggernaut into being in a different
position now again it's the nature of
comics everything that changes
goes back to being the way that it was
before so somewhere along the line
something's gonna happen
and juggernaut's gonna go back to being
his old self right it's the nature of
comics nothing stays changed for long
right everything just always goes back
to to the status quo
but for this time that we get it it
looks like it's pretty cool right so
kind of jumping back to to where he's
basically been captured and confined
inside of this uh this this you know
base of operations for arnhem zola
of course you have d cell jump in and
that's where things get interesting here
because one of the things to understand
this is more of an interim comic right
so there's not a whole lot of action
going on here we do get kind of a return
or at least a new status quo for
juggernaut but beyond that there's not a
whole lot happening instead
diesel basically jumps out of this this
you know uh this helicopter uses her
power to kind of slow herself down so
she doesn't smash under the ground in
the mountains and die
and then from there arnhem zola makes
his presence known and basically tells
us what we already know right that for
years he's been experimenting
on mutants because mutants are now
considered to be a rare commodity right
that where there was no curcua there was
no centralized location whereby all
mutants existed and nobody could access
it mutants used to be all over the place
right they were just in different places
around the world just kind of making
their living and doing their thing and
it was very easy to access any mutant
and to basically kidnap them experiment
on them if that's what you wanted to do
but now that all the mutants are
essentially under the purview of kokoa
and the protection of the island and the
power of those who were on the island
one doesn't simply just walk into krakow
you don't just simply go in there and
then take a mutant and leave doesn't
really work that way right i mean you'd
likely get yourself
killed doing it and so mutants are now a
highly sought after commodity like
adamantium the whole point behind this
is
they're a rare commodity and so arnhem
zola able to get his hands on a mutant
and then in turn mess with their dna and
then
you know kind of sell that off to the
highest bidder is a huge source of
income that kind of seems to be what's
going on here now
for its part when diesel goes against
primus she's nowhere near prepared for
that level of power and so she's
ultimately conquered as well
and so with that being the case and
juggernaut seeing what's happening and
realizing they're basically gonna kill
her and then kind of extract her dna
break it down figure out how her powers
work
find a way to duplicate it and then sell
that off to somebody he of course
smashes out of his containment cell and
then immediately goes after primus now
when that happens
prime minister of course attacks
juggernaut but juggernaut does one of
those big thunderclaps and then
basically shatters primus into a whole
bunch of different pieces right doesn't
really seem to kill him as much as
incapacitate him but then from there he
goes directly after arnhem zola now when
he frees d
cell she of course goes after artem zola
as well and then seeks to destroy him
only for us to find out that arnhem zola
has been conscripted
right he's been forced into servitude by
some other organization out there that's
really pulling the strings and so he's
not really the mastermind here there's a
much bigger plan of foot and there's a
much bigger organization
out there again it's an interim comic
this is the empire strikes back of the
story right it's just
it's more informational than anything
else it doesn't really have a whole lot
of action and there's certainly no
conclusion here it doesn't really kind
of give us the idea
that there's a much bigger situation
going on so again it's cool you know i i
dig it it's certainly one of those who
probably could have coupled
with the next video with the next comic
that came out and it probably would have
done us some good in terms of having a
little more going on in this particular
story but
you know this is also a little important
here because having it as its own
individual story gives us the ability to
understand
better what's going on as opposed to
having to rush through it and then
making up for things later on down the
road right so
again not a whole lot doing here but it
bobby does have a few bits of important
information that'll become relevant
later on but if you guys are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do